become what happened to my Medicare two
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another episode from the
house the house show
inshallah as you guys know on this
episode on this specific set it's more
calm relaxed mellow and we've got an
amazing guest may Allah bless him
someone off really wanted to meet been
watching his videos if I'm leavin
mistaken maybe even before I came to
Islam I think I was watching some of
your videos
I'm the remain a bless your brother Ben
well yes that's why you need to Train
masha'Allah how many stripes have you
got three stripes mashallah BJJ you know
I'm considering getting two BJJ I
believe me a boxing but you know I'm
trying to get a job down so you know but
all free so free striped black belt free
straps yes
inshallah yeah so I found so creative
how many jobs may Allah bless us Allah
yeah I'm interested in BJJ you know need
to know how to work on the ground as
well it's and I see some of the stuff
that you do and Hum Dil I'm gonna Tek
some of your videos also about a healthy
eating it's quite interesting feels
really important making those little
life changes because a lot of people are
suffering from cancer and especially I
hate them like that
may Allah bless him he's going through
his well my Allah game she found
everyone it's a very deadly disease but
brother Dean so I would in a reaction
video so this is more for the youngsters
you know for our youth inshallah so I
found this video on Instagram I found it
very very interesting and also you
talked a lot about you know Christianity
you would guess and the oneness of Allah
so I wanted to watch it together and I
want your reaction to inshallah
so here we go so this this this guy on
the right he's he's speaking to her some
say that this guy is a YouTube or
Instagram abut that this girl was
speaking to someone else but he was
pretending to speak to her but besides
the point if you see what you see what I
mean it's just a where's Jesus
yes that's a good question because he
used to walk the earth like us Brenda
read the Bible so yes if I read the
Bible I'll pray about read the Bible
well I can do that my lady
thank you say what Audrey people do
rather than I I sure that's so true
okay well look call me back and you read
in a commie bit you say where's G okay
so I found that so interesting you know
like I was just randomly watching it and
she's reading it she's a little child I
know how she how old she is you know one
thing about me I can tell how old the
child is this is probably I don't free
sometimes but it's so interesting as a
child that you know the Fatah life we
believe it the innate disposition how it
just kicks in you can see her face and
the beginning she's reading and she's
absorbing like the face you know we have
this like you know when something just
clicks when someone says something to
you yeah I mean it was quite profound I
just found it really amazing how as a
young child yeah that fitrah just kicked
in you know Anna what's your take on her
life since you know it reminds me
there's this study that I often quote I
think it was it was done at the Oxford
University yes yeah yeah yeah 52
researchers you know they concluded at
the end and this is not this is from a
secular institution yes it's not exactly
any kind of religious so they concluded
through all these studies that the
belief in God is natural and pretty much
you know what one of the researchers
from there he talks about how if a child
you know was left alone it would grow up
to believe in a creator a lot of these
things that's part of nature but not
he's what
he's doing he's nurturing he's trying to
nurture to go ahead and make her believe
that Jesus in size about God but what
has me thinking here's what guys learned
about himself you know it reminds me of
I think this was it mark 13:32 when
Jesus peace be upon him he was asked
when is that day when is the hour
yeah right yeah yeah he was like yeah I
don't know it's like why you asking me
please
yeah yeah no man no the angels are but
God yeah creator yeah so this is
something because when the people know I
mean for instance okay we talked about
if I'm looking for a bodyguard yeah
right I'm looking for a bodyguard I want
someone who fits a certain description
right he's gonna be black belt like
yourself buddy what well trained combat
yes weapons disarmament weapons
engagement and all these other things
there's qualities that you need to look
for for someone who's gonna be your body
go yeah yeah you're not going to get
someone who's in crutches yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly looking for qualities of
the creator mmm he's got qualities
exactly yeah when I say he i mean he's
not this language yes so now there's
certain qualities one that he's
all-knowing the exactly the crater's
all-knowing right he doesn't live or die
yes right he doesn't eat sleep rest go
to the bathroom exactly Jesus peace be
upon him who we love and adore is one of
the mightiest messengers ever sent to
mankind became the same message that you
always hear me repeated he worshipped
the crater not the creation like all the
other messengers at Muhammad just being
the last Mississippi upon them all he
now he ate he slept and he didn't know
and this this is one of the most
powerful things that he just he didn't
he didn't he told me that doesn't like
put him down or anything of course right
here this is something just that's
showing that now if God is all-knowing
Jesus wasn't he can't be God period yeah
nice it's amazing you know it's just
when we sometimes give vowel to people
and you see that fitrah it kicks in you
know it just it just it just happens you
speak to them and the only they can't
even deny it and it's like they just
want to disbelief
you know they it's just like you looking
at me thinking oh you know yourself
within yourself that he come because
Mohammad each other we went to Ghana and
this is where I've got this shirt from
this nice African thing going on here
and we were speaking to them and in a
nutshell my Mario's having a discussion
which I'll link the video with two
rappers in Ghana and they were saying
right now god can't eat or drink you
know but then they would come back to
kind of defend the Trinity ever since he
actually didn't see what they were
learning but you can see there was no
God can eat or drink but well like this
is what you believe and they're like not
really we don't so you can see the fit
or kicking and the finish is just you
know it ignites and this is what you
know makes Islam so beautiful because if
there's any Christians watching this you
know one of the things that's so unique
about Islam besides other religions is
that you know we don't just single out a
lot in what he does his actions is of
sustainable provider and this is a lot
of people believe in this the Croatian
believes in this the pagan I love this
idea we accept you know Allah created us
you know but where did they mess up
where did they go wrong they went wrong
with Allah only here like it were
targeted only here like singling out in
worship yeah so that's what's different
in Islam that we have that's really
unique but when we worship God we
worship Him alone and this is where a
lot of other religious belief systems
have gone wrong where they've said okay
and even some people in Islam where they
would go through the Prophet Muhammed
like directly they were asked to him and
be it other people be through Jesus be
it through a lot of Buddhist believe
that but a lot of people they go through
down down this room why because they
thought they were really righteous and
you know we're sinners this this notion
is from Shaytan you know Allah sponsored
says you know Jannik turned to me alone
you and me no partners all does not need
no partners and another part of it is
his asthma was so fast his names and
attributes which comes to his door
knowing they're all powerful
so we come and say look at this this
girl here this young little girl she
acknowledged she acknowledged Allah God
Almighty hold on a second he's good how
does know automatically kicks you know
it clicks in and also for example he's
the most powerful you know but he got
crucified by his own creation you know
hey old Janna it just makes sense and
this is what makes its lamp so unique
and brothers and sisters if you're
watching this our Christian friends this
is what makes Islam Islam and it's very
unique and inshallah if you can look
more into it read the Quran it was just
a little reaction video or it is
anything
you want to say I mean I know we're
short on time but this is one of those
when you talk about the pure monotheism
do heed yes this is something that fits
with the human nature this is yes people
get drawn yes laughing about everything
else I mean you don't see I mean you
know that people attack this that and
the other it takes some more context to
it yeah but there this is something the
the pure monotheism you don't see the
theology of Islam many people attacking
it let you know that there's nothing
worthy of worship or so the creator to
happen exactly this is something that
connects with human nature that's
something that we call people too before
you get into all the other things yeah
why can't I have a girlfriend you know
what Islam says about you know all these
other issues side notes yeah many thick
issues yet right here the jurisprudence
of Islam this is what we call people to
call out yes
to the creator of the loan people are
seeking purpose they want to no purpose
yes if they're smart you know if you
ended up on the moon you want to know
why you're there
exactly open say maybe they have a
Starbucks chill but at the end of the
day why why are you there on the moon
exactly there why you on this earth for
what you live and that's it you know go
to some parties kick it that's it
exactly
but the homework that I usually leave
people to do is call out to the Creator
yes to the ultimate reality Ethel and
ask for guidance it's simple its
straightforward
exactly no I mean yes your Creator Allah
exactly you don't need to go through you
know that yeah I love it and have that
song or secretary or let me go for him
Allah doesn't need that you know just go
directly to Allah insha Allah
yeah that's about it brothers and
sisters inshallah hope you guys are
benefited inshallah if there's any
specific we actually do is that you have
that we haven't seen comment on the
section below give us the links we can
check them out and do reaction with our
guests inshallah Boveda may Allah bless
you for coming mashaallah was a pleasure
inshallah salaam alaikum what happens
later okay